start so our next speaker is suguman
bansal who is a
researcher at university of pennsylvania
and she will tell us about synthesis of
coordination programs
and with that thank you sugarman for
joining us today
if there is supposed to be audio coming
i'm
not hearing any can you hear me now
yes no it's great thank you and do you
see the slides in full screen let's do a
quick mic check
yes all right good okay cool
so thank you very much thank you russ
and thank you organizers for inviting me
to the workshop
it's truly an honor to be here at simons
um
so today i'm gonna talk about i'm gonna
present coordination
as another application to reactive
synthesis
and i'll discuss its current and and its
future
uh this is based on joint work with
kedarnam joshi and yaniv saar
and this paper appeared at popple last
year
so taking a leaf from uh
from near's talk today that we're really
looking at these settings where there
are multiple agents
and we want to design a program that
coordinates between them
and that's what we'll call a
coordination program and
it's very and there are plenty of
examples that we
of these kinds of programs that we see
in our regular daily life
for instance a centralized coordinator
in an iot setup
would be a coordination program here on
this diagram in particular i've shown a
thermostat
and its task is to coordinate between a
room temperature sensor
a heater and an ac to ensure that the
room temperature stays ambient and
other examples could include an
automated where industrial warehouse
where a centralized coordinator
coordinates between these
several robots to ensure effective
collaboration
or at a much larger scale the web
services where you have a centralized
server
that coordinates between several
independently operating servers
all of these are examples of
coordination programs
and what is of interest to us is that if
you think of it
abstractly a coordination program is
nothing but a reactive system
and here in this abstract diagram the
coordination program is in blue
and the environment is given by the set
of all agents or devices
between which the coordination program
attempts to coordinate
and this is reactive because the devices
and the coordinates the environment in
this case which are the devices
the environment and the coordination
program coordinate through a sequence of
inputs and outputs
which is exactly what a reactive system
does
turns out just like for every reactive
system uh specifying the intent
of the program is simpler for instance
in the thermostat
example the intent is simply that the
amp that the thermostat should maintain
ambient temperature
so to me this sounds like the perfect
recipe for
a synthesis problem so we'll define
coordination synthesis
and the task is to automatically
generate a coordination program
from a high level uh specification
now if if if the description of
coordinates now this looks very similar
to what we see in
typical reactive synthesis formulations
say something like synthesis from lts
specifications
and if if that were the case we could
have simply packed our bags
and said that the problem is solved
fortunately that's not the case there
are certain characteristics to this
coordination setup
which make it more unique and and and
make it more unique with which make it
more unique and more interesting
from the perspective of of designing the
synthesis algorithm
so the one of the first things
one of the first characteristics is that
the environment in this case it's it's
much more
sophisticated typically in reactive
synthesis settings the environment is
simply
an adversarial system that generates
inputs
uh generates inputs for the coordination
program
but in this case the environment
consists of
several complex looking agents or
devices
for example these agents could be things
like
room temperature sensors ac's heaters
and so on
so they're complex they have complex
rich space complex
rich structures and possibly even the
ability to communicate among themselves
so they have some sort of an interface
and all of that
so one could say that well all of this
could be
encoded in some form of some form of ltl
and then but the argument would be that
encoding such rich structure and such
communication
protocols in ltl would
defeat the purpose of synthesis which is
that the specification is easy to
specify
next from the perspective of what the
function of the coordination program is
in this setup the coordination program
should be able to function under
asynchrony
and this is because the environment the
devices inside the environment
each operates independently so it would
be
incorrect to assume that there is a
global clock
along which all of the devices are
synchronized instead each device
operates as it
at its own block so there is a synchrony
so whatever coordination program we try
to synthesize
it should operate under asynchrony
and finally the coordination program
only has
partial information about the state
space of all of the devices
this is because think of it as an api
the api only exposes the signature but
we never really need to know
what happens inside so similarly these
devices
they may possibly interact privately
among themselves
without really exposing all of its
functionalities to the coordination
program
so despite this partial information the
coordination need
program needs to operate correctly
so these are the features the
characteristics that make coordination
synthesis
harder or harder than
regular reactive synthesis and that's
really what we are trying to solve here
so the problem is to formulate solve and
demonstrate coordination synthesis
and from the pers and the idea in
formalizing the problem
is to ensure that the problem is easy to
specify
uh and then from the perspective of
algorithm design
uh to the best of our knowledge uh prior
work has not looked
at combining all of the characteristics
of reactivity asynchrony partial
information
and to do all of this with rich ltl
specifications
and finally through some through some
case studies
we'll demonstrate the utility of having
a coordination synthesis too
so now diving a little deep what is the
high level specification here
well to to specify the intent of the
coordination program we will use
ltl uh what is in
what is important is that we will also
specify the device descriptions
as part of the input and for this we
will use the well-established notion of
communicating sequential processes csps
and the benefit of using these of using
csps
is that in this language we can
we can we can easily specify these
devices
in a way where these properties of rich
structure
communication models and interface
between what is
what actions are visible to the
environment and what aren't
are available for free so i'm assuming
this audience is well aware of what ltl
is
so i'll quickly give you a brief
description of what csps are
so in csp each device
is represented as a collection of csp
processes
and you can visualize it as this finite
as a finite state machine
where each state is called a process and
trans
and there are transitions between these
processes on actions
in in this talk processes will be
indicated by capital letters
and the actions will be partitioned into
public actions which are the actions
visible
to all other devices and private actions
which are the actions visible only to
that
only to that device and transitions
between any two processes
are called revolutions so uh there is
so on action a so the process e
evolves to uh process e0 on the public
action a0
and similarly e0 evolves to
itself on the private action b0
uh and of course and this uh this
language
also allows for structural
non-determinism so from each state
it is possible from from each process it
is possible to evolve to two or more
different processes on the same action
and here is a small example of what a
device could look like
in csp we could very well think of them
as finite state machines
now when i say two such device two or
more devices
uh interact with one another intuitively
we could think of
these as products of these finite state
machines
where the rules of products where the
rules of how to construct the product
are given by the rules of csp synchro
given by the rules of how csps interact
or synchronize
and for this the rules are different for
public actions and private actions
on public actions the idea is that two
processes can evolve together
if they share a public action for
instance here
there are two processes p0 p1 both of
which share
an action a public action a so then
collectively
the the collectively the sync the collec
collectively p zero p one can evolve to
q zero q one
however if uh in this
other example p zero and p one do not
share a common action
a common public action so no evolution
occurs in the product
about private actions each process
can evolve on a private action by itself
it does not there does not have to by
itself
without any dependence on other
processes in the system
so here uh p0 process p0 has a private
action
and it it evolves to q0 without
ever interacting with the process p1
here is an example just to give you an
idea of what happens when
two two devices may interact here i have
a device that initiates that process e
and a device that initiates at process n
and when both of these interact despite
both despite both of these processes
being deterministic
the presence of private actions is
enough
for there to be multiple executions
uh from the coordination of these two
devices
and the fact that uh there could be
non-determinism in the environment
in this case e just magnifies the
possibility
of all executions so
given this formalism the coordination
synthesis problem is defined as follows
given an environment give a given a set
of
n csp divide n devices
given in the form of csps e1 to en
and an ltl specification s can we
generate
a coordinator m also in csp
such that when e when this when when the
environment e and the synthesized
coordinator
m uh compose then all possible execution
satisfy the specification s
now this is clearly a problem of
reactive synthesis where
e is the environment m is the reactive
system to generate
and s is the specification
but there are challenges in designing an
algorithm for this
and those come from the inherent
complexities of
the of the problem domain the first
being
of course partial information uh in
synthesizing while synthesizing
what in in the algorithm design the
coordinator
is may not be aware of the current state
of e
and this is because of the environment
and this could be possibly due to two
reasons
one is the fact that there is inherent
non-determinism in the environment
and then the fact that the environment
could take private actions
without the information of without ever
having to inform the
inform the environment as a result of
which it may not the environment may not
know
uh as a result of which the coordinator
will not know
the actual state space in addition to
partial information
uh it given partial information it also
becomes harder to ensure deadlock
freedom
for instance in this case if the
environment is given as such
then a coordinator that takes the action
a naught would result in a deadlock
and this is because together e and m
would evolve to the state e0
from which the coordinator m would not
be able to
coordinate with the environment anymore
however if we if if if
however a coordinator the a coordinator
that takes the action a1
will not deadlock in the system and the
ability
so the algorithm must have the ability
to design a coordinator
that does not deadlock despite not
knowing the actual state space of the
environment
and if this was not enough then there's
also asynchrony
from the from the coordinator's
perspective it only sees the public
actions
it never sees the private actions so it
doesn't know how many private actions
have taken place
or what the private actions are
so what it has to ensure is that
although the coordinator only sees the
sequence of public actions
for every possible expansion of that
sequence
that is valid in the environment and by
expansion i mean
uh all possible ways in which
private actions could could be uh could
be interspersed in the sequence
the specification should be true on each
one of those
and now our core result is that all of
these challenges
could be resolved using automata
theoretic reductions
and what we show is that the
coordination synthesis problem given an
environment e
and a specification s can be transformed
into one
can be reduced into the problem of
regular reactive synthesis
from a transform specification that
we'll call ts here
so uh because we had heard a talk on
uh so in order to construct the
so now the question is how is this
transform specification
uh generated and this happens over a
sequence of
transformations uh from the automaton
for the specification s and on the
environment e
but there is one drawback with the
flowchart i've shown you here
and the reason is that the size of
so so if you think of the pipeline that
we've
generated here in order to solve
coordination synthesis from e and s
we we can generate uh this transform
specification
uh we can construct its automaton and
then pass that
as the input to any state of the art
reactive synthesis tool
and then we can solve and then uh and
then we could generate
a coordinator m if it exists
but the issue with this pipeline is that
the size of the automaton for the
transform specification
is exponential in the size of the
environment
and the number of states in the
automaton for s
and this by no means uh would be
uh with this by no means would be uh
existing synthesis algorithms will not
be able to
scale up will not be able to scale up
will not be able to synthesize
for such a large automaton
so what we do is actually the following
we observe that constructing the
automaton
for the negation of the transform
specification
can be done very efficiently i'll not go
into the details of how this happens
but to construct the automaton for the
negation
we only incur a blow up that doubles the
number of states
uh in e and this and the automaton for
the specification
now if you remember from what if you
remember the key idea
from the top and bound the on from the
tutorial bounded synthesis
is that if in a bounded synthesis tool
you want to construct you want to
synthesize for a given specification
then it internally constructs the
automaton for the negation of the
specification
and that's exactly the insight we can
use here
because the construction of the negation
of the desired automaton
construction of the automaton of the
negation of the specification is
efficient
we actually use a bounded synthesis
based tool
in the back end to solve the full to
solve coordination synthesis
so just to look at what the complete
procedure is
at the front end the inputs are an ldl
specification s
and a set of environments e1 to en
each ei denoting one device in the
coordination setup
and then these inputs are processed by
their respective state-of-the-art tools
once the processing is complete uh
the the inputs are sent into this core
reduction part
uh we do with the we perform the
reduction through symbolic operations
and what this means in terms of the
number of variables introduced
is that because the state space or is
only doubled
this co-reduction only introduces one
extra state variable
to construct the automaton for the
negation
of the desired specification and then
this
can be passed into a backend
state-of-the-art
bounded synthesis tool and that will
return realizable
if if it'll return it will return a
desired coordinator if
if the input instance is realizable and
will return unrealizable otherwise
i do want to make i do want to make
another point here
so typically uh so so the tool we use
here is bose
it is the state-of-the-art tool for
boundary synthesis
and typically internally bozi will
convert
the synthesis problem into either
solving a qbf
problem or a sat problem uh and
and the encoding here is done for
general purpose specifications
what we what we observe is that if we
and if we incorporate some domain
knowledge in creating these encodings
then the performance of the coordination
synthesis procedure
is improved by many fold
and now to give you an example of how
coordination synthesis can help
so here i've shown you how the
three i've shown you i'm going back to
the thermostat example
so the idea is that we want to
synthesize a thermostat
that coordinates between a room
temperature sensor
a heater and an ac process
some of these actions are public
and actions in coordination and so on we
don't need to get into the details of
all of that
but what is but to synthesize this
thermostat
we could start off by saying uh in ltl
to maintain ambient temperature and then
when we
pass this through but when we and then
uh
and when we pass it through our
synthesis tool it'll tell us well the
problem is realizable
but the the the coordinate the
thermostatic synthesized
was one that just did not interact with
any of the devices
so what was happening internally is that
the the thermostat figured out that even
if it never
interacts with any of the systems then
infinitely often
ambient temperature will be attained
because of
the changes in the because of changes in
the in the temperature of the physical
environment but now this is obviously
not
although this is correct with respect to
the specification it's
by no means the intention of the
specifier
so over a sequence of iterations
we could keep refining the specification
to get
uh to to get rid of these undesired
behaviors
until we are satisfied with the kind of
speci with the kind
of um of coordinator in this
case a thermostat until we are satisfied
with the thermostat
and and this is really how we envision
using a coordination synthesis kind of
tool
and the and the reason and and the basic
idea is that
we have been able to lift the debugging
step from
low level debugging on the system to
debugging at the higher level
on the specification sugar man just a
node here is your friendly time keeper
we are 22 minutes and i am on my last
last slide which coincidentally is also
the 20 second slide
so this talk was about coordination
synthesis
uh and what i did was i formulated the
problem
where devices are defined are
where the devices are given uh as csp
environments
and the specification is ltl and from
the algorithms perspective
it's interesting because uh to do two
coordination synthesis
we have to com we can combine asynchrony
partial information and the full
expressiveness of ltl
what i did not cover in the stock but is
an important point
is that the algorithm like that
coordination synthesis
is p space hard in the size of the
environment
and the algorithm i presented is
exponential
although the reduction is although the
reduction is linear and efficient
the full synthesis algorithm is
exponential
in the environment and exponential in
the number of devices
and this clearly is a scalability bonded
neck
in if we were if we wanted to make
synthesis or coordination synthesis
uh to become somewhat more
uh useful for real life applications
and this i feel there is still a lot of
opportunity to
improve coordination synthesis and
perhaps
reactive synthesis in general for
instance
in our case we saw that improving by
doing
domain specific encodings uh performance
can be improved many fold
so probably the lesson to learn here is
that if we are using
synthesis tools as a backend it may be
more effective
to open up the hood and try to search
for opportunities
for improvements and similarly one could
make
several there is there are several
opportunities for innovations
at the algorithm level for reactor
synthesis and
those would be interesting directions to
explore in the future
um i i would conclude
my talk with that uh thank you all for
tuning in
from your respective time zones
thank you um other questions
for the chat or the q a
while we're doing that uh we can
transition to the next talk
um if you can stop sharing
thank you and so our final talk of the
session
is by julie nuke